[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIC IGLESIAS: Howdy, folks.
My name's Vic Iglesias.
I'm a Cloud Solutions
Architect with Google Cloud.
And today, I'd like to
walk through a architecture
of a GitOps based
CI/CD pipeline.
When we talk about
CI/CD pipelines,
we really have to think about
three different personas--
the developers, the operators,
and the security engineers.
Our developers are going
to have their own Git
repository, where they store
their application code.
That application
code is also going
to be able to kick off
continuous integration--
whenever you get a commit.
And that continuous
integration job
is used to create an artifact.
When we're talking about
deploying to Kubernetes,
our artifacts are
container images.
So once continuous integration
creates that container image,
it's going to store it
in a container registry.
That process is going
to go ahead and notify
another repository that
something has changed.
In that repository,
we have our operators
creating configuration,
that then
says how our application is
actually going to be deployed.
In order to manage
that configuration,
our Kubernetes
manifest, we're going
to use a tool called Customize.
Customize is going to add in
that container image reference
into our config, and then commit
that to Kubernetes manifest
into a Git repository.
That Git repository
stores the state
that we want to apply
into our environments.
The first place where
we store that state
is within the staging
branch of this repository,
and that goes ahead
and deploys it straight
to our staging environment.
Now, developers can
test out those changes,
see them live in a
staging environment.
And once they're
happy, they're going
to tell the operators
that they want
to make a push to production--
or the operators can
decide to do that on their own.
In order to do
that, they're going
to emerge from the staging
branch of this repository
into the master
branch, and that's
going to propagate those
changes down into the production
environment.
Now, we haven't yet talked about
how we get those production
environments to be secure.
The way we're
going to do that is
by letting the
security engineers
have their own repository.
And that repository is
going to store the state
that we're going to
use to apply policy
across all of our clusters.
We're going to use Anthem's
config management to do that.
We can store that state
in a repository that
has a structure that
allows us to apply
to select clusters
or all clusters
a certain set of configurations.
For those security engineers,
those configurations
are going to be things like
role-based access control
policies, quotas for
various applications,
and things like restricting the
ability of containers to run
[INAUDIBLE].
So now they can make all of
those commits in an audible Git
repo, and then have them apply
to all of their production
infrastructure.
Thank you for listening.
Please come visit us at the
Google Cloud booth at Kubecon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]